okay hi everyone we are doing a design
review for some things for
version 13.3 of awesome language
today we're talking about visualization
all right static and dynamic
highlightings that our main topic here
yes
okay
so where do I start
so
well maybe you want to start with
Dynamic highlighting so if you go to
that dynamic
dynamic plot highlight or
Dynamic Point highlight is a good place
to start
okay
there are no examples in the agenda
notebook right correct
so I'm using
and it's turned on by default so
you know if you do let me tell you
something let me tell you something I am
fed up with having situations where for
example something like a histogram
and where you have to explicitly enable
Dynamics in a notebook to get something
like histogram or pie chart to work but
it comes out gray without Dynamics being
able so that problem has to be solved
do you know what I'm talking about I I
know what you're talking about has that
problem been solved because you can't
ship this without that problem being
solved yes the problem has been solved
how has it been solved the necessary
functionality is whitelisted
okay why wasn't it before
and you have that problem for years why
wasn't that done before
I mean in many places it is or
no but why wasn't that done specifically
for the case of like pie charts and
histograms I mean pie chart should not
have that problem
okay all about histogram
likewise okay but it did have that
problem it does have that problem in
version 13.2 it does have that problem
at least 13.1 it has that problem
I would assume there's something else
going on okay but we got to figure out
what it is because we can't ship
something where that's a possibility
am I making sense
so how do I make a notebook untrusted
um
go to your uh is it in the preferences
dialog I can't remember
code well
uh preferences dialog to security
settings
okay
edit untrusted directories
added untrusted directories
okay all right so I'm going to take
how do I specify that I'm going to take
the directory for this
directory open close I'm going to put
that in my map
whoops no no book directory
okay
and now I'm going to go over here and
say edit and trusted directories add
or it even has a browse I don't care so
that that
she's like well other quotes certainly
should allow the quotes
okay
okay now let me go and open that
thank you
I can't tell
that works click click on the orange
sector
I wonder why that's
yes correct Behavior it's not Dynamics
now
but what shouldn't it be doing something
different ux wise
if you Mouse over one of the histogram
sectors
yeah it's changing the edge form right
it's very subtle I wonder why the pie
chart sectors aren't popping when you
click on them
well
okay let me show you this we've got to
fix this problem right we've got to fix
that problem
um I think we should do some kind of ux
review
um
about this stuff okay about it's really
quite important I mean this no no this
can't fail type things agreed and that's
what we had as at the outset and we
thought we had it that that was
oh you say it's on by default
yep
I don't really like what it looks like
I I like the functionality I don't like
what it looks like that's fine
have anybody from design here
I don't think we have okay so we're
going to need a meeting which has people
from design to talk about this right
sure
um
you know one day we should figure out
how to get rid of the need for that
evaluate
let's let's discuss that not today but
okay yep
what's that nonsense
what are those
I don't know what they are they're
self-test errors
okay
you can screen capture them
okay that's cute that those change color
I was wondering what that was going to
do it's a good idea I think it's too
loud but it's a good idea to have them
change color
one of the things is that our tool tips
look very old-fashioned on Windows they
have this faded yellow look
okay it just looks last century
basically well but let's fix it exactly
so we're fixing it here but we want to
fix it globally yeah well that's a good
thing I think that they look crummy here
as well
well I think they look a thousand times
better than the system
okay no no no I mean I'm saying these
ones here which are traditional tool
tips yeah
don't look very good exactly okay fine
so let's get a design meeting please and
I don't know when we're going to fit it
in but we need to do it quickly
to look at the graphic design of all
these elements
they're both default tool tips and your
new tool tips makes sense yep
okay
so what's the status of this
um Dynamic plot highlight
what the hell's Dynamic highlight it's a
wrapper
let's do this first and we'll come to it
and we can change the names and all of
that yeah
I should be ignoring the red
yes yes obviously I don't know I don't
know because I might have typed it wrong
it might be a little bit easier to see
with fewer curves
yeah it's nice
no question it's nice
except that
something is really wrong maybe it's not
helped by the fact that it's a non-fixed
width font
I don't know you just look very messy
those numbers
um
it's nice which other ones should I look
at here which are which other things are
and style
I don't know if it's combining the
Style with the drop line in that case
well it's not
I probably shouldn't it
I think so
because it combined the ball
all right what's the name for the ball
is the one that has the
the numbering
but then style doesn't have the
numbering correct
it's a little thicken or something
and Nostalgia seems very generic
I mean it is I mean it's generic in the
sense that
in a sense there's something slightly
different in this plot than it does in
plots
yeah when you have points versus curves
look the thing people really want
is also the zoom ability stuff which I
don't know whether that's I mean that
that's not in here but yes that is also
okay so let me look at this plop
that's cute
that's nice so long as it scales well
I think he had a
that's good it's good performance well
done yeah I think there's a threshold
where it cuts off but I don't remember
what the number is for it
well it's less than 10 to five
right
now in a situation like this
you could just give
rather than highlighting an individual
point you could just still give
something that is the coordinates of a
given location
potentially yeah
I mean link you should could still do
something in this case it's perfectly
reasonable
yeah so you know when it cuts off we go
to like a generic mechanism that doesn't
care about the geometry
it's just a coordinate based thing
nothing in 3D yet right now we're just
doing curves and surf or Curves and
points
okay
and so
now let's say for example if you grab
your plot example that's partially on
screen
um and you
yep do the
you know turn it into like you know sine
and cosine or whatever
the sale yep yeah so so that it's an
actual yeah exactly
right and so now you can use Dynamic
highlights
yes instead of the option say and
so what is the term isn't don't we have
a term highlighted
we have highlighted which is the drawer
with the yellow background thing yep
um
to take off the option just yeah it's
are they still
what's the default I mean it's no
that's not what it's looking but
yeah I thought that was
I mean do you remember I thought we were
gonna have it so that
the automatic highlighting was off if
you had explicit
or is it are they combining
well I mean I would have thought this
Dynamic highlight thing would be a
thicken highlighting
we have a problem of that uh the mouse
is hitting the curve to show the style
or for the point so because they're
competing each other so we need to
figure that out
um and if you would like to try it could
you try the second argument as a style
like a red in the dynamic highlight
wrapper
oops
that yes running into the testing issue
I guess
right okay fine all right so it's not
working yeah um
knows that
well so so
highlight and
so so the static highlights you know the
wrapper highlight and the
option plot highlights
are
things that generally require a position
of where to highlight
um I'm sorry so that's a completely
different idea then
although I thought we did have a no
argument yes uh could you could you
check your version of um external I'm
running today's and it's working fine
well I'm running whatever I was given
no I'm not running today so somebody
should have checked before this meeting
if you needed me to be running the one
from today
sorry I'm just used to you always having
the latest
look I only have the latest they build
correctly they clearly validated right
when I started this meeting so it's the
first time I've used this version and
I'm surprised because I was using the X
kernel on Friday
yes so
okay
let me also make another comment which
is that
something I've had trouble with like for
for histogram okay
I really don't want any delay when I
have a giant histogram because the
stupid highlighting thing which I don't
care about for a big histogram you see
what I'm saying it's absolutely
Irrelevant for a big histogram
yeah
but I just don't want to see it I mean I
really really don't want to see it and I
don't want the thing being grindingly
slow because it's running some crazy
thing like that
and so how do we deal with that again
another you know another issue that um
yeah I mean this highlighting is both
ugly
and I don't really see the point of it I
just don't see the point
for something like this I mean it's just
pure Amusement value
is the tooltip useful for you
mildly
okay now it's not doing it anymore which
is totally merciful
yes and it turns off after okay there
are cases though where
I mean I don't know have you tested it
carefully that there are no cases where
it's like grindingly slowed down by
having something dynamic
do you understand what I'm saying I
understand what you're saying and we've
done some tests and it hasn't been
exhausted yet okay so we need to make
sure to do that right right and so
better to switch it off than to have
something grindingly slow exactly
okay because that hasn't been working so
far
uh by the way I see on our live stream
is asking a question that I was going to
ask as well does it work in the cloud
it will it will so yeah we perhaps not
immediately but that can be a mid uh
release cycle update to the cloud
have you talked to the cloud yes yes yes
yes yes is anybody in this meeting from
the cloud team no
okay does this require native Graphics
in the cloud
yes
so it's not I mean it's on a completely
different time scale
yes
yeah whatever
look it's nice functionality okay
I think that we need it in the cloud you
know as well as on a desktop sure I
think that this is you know where
people's expectation is going
and so if we just turn it all off all
the time or say that we're not going to
have it then yeah no I I understand we
need to have it you know it's part of
modernizing all kinds of things you know
math plotlet doesn't have anything like
this people go to other libraries like
plotly and other things to get
interactivity whatever
the
we should have had it years ago we
haven't we've had it in both mouth for
10 years
you know an overlay of the stuff a move
from Alpha
um nothing this complete no no no it is
complete no no and we wrote A lot of
that that sin was from alpha right yeah
who's the we
the this team
um no the stuff that Stephen's talking
about they did no oh maybe I missed it
but there was a bunch of things we did
right like that we did some stuff to
help her yes okay
just as well
okay so there's a variety of options
here for how this works which is great
um
and Alternate appearances and so on and
so this the difference between sort of
the use cases between interactive and
Stat you know dynamic and static is
is and that if you're sending it to sort
of dead media like PDFs yeah you know
and articles you typically want the
static things you want it to remain
there
I know you know and that's part of what
you kind of communicating whereas in the
other cases you're exploring
typically and I know I don't know I
understand that but I mean so so hold on
let's walk through the names here okay
this functionality looks nice except
that it needs graphic design which yep
we need to get that I mean is Tim here
so Tim is watching the stream you can
probably quickly join if you want hi Tim
join us
um
can we get Jeremy also
I'll grab him see whether we can
um but let's talk about names
sure okay
so let's look at what other names we
have in the Highlight space
okay
so highlight mesh what does it do
static highlight of you know sub mesh
or parts of a mesh it's the same it's
similar to what highlight graph does but
we'll do what does this do
sorry that's the one that we just
introduced oh okay that's the what is
the Highlight what is that oh
highlighted oh God we got to make these
names are not going to work
okay so highlighted
highlighted does that
right for a for a but highlighted in
here doesn't do anything is that true
correct
makes it not render
okay another thing you know it's just as
if you wrapped it in Foo yeah okay
so
let's understand the other meanings of
highlight like mesh highlight mesh all
those kinds of things so highlight graph
mesh image are similar
in that
they give you know a big composite
object and you specify what in there
okay so let's take a look here
but now in a graph
if I were to say
okay so I've got a complete graph there
let's say I I say Edge list
of this
and now I wrap when I make a graph out
of that
can I I can rap style Yes red around
that yeah
that's part of the construction yeah
yeah
okay nice okay if I want to label if I
want to have a node so let's say I say
Style
not sure that that works but if you give
the node list for sure but let's let's
probably works
no no it doesn't so you need an explicit
node list and you can write okay
right if I if I have a node list there
so if I have that be five and then I
have one two three
four or five and I say
you know Style
how do I make this thing bigger
I think you can do large I can't
remember exactly what all the keys are
that definitely works yeah there should
be a way to make it larger maybe Point
size large
no see this is the type of thing in
terms of usability that we really need
to grind down
it's going to produce some message or
something rather than just dumbly not
doing it because I just have no idea
whether it was not implemented somebody
forgot you know whatever else get what
I'm saying can you try larger
yeah but I mean I I will but I'm yeah it
didn't work so you don't even know what
so can you please add this to the list
of things that we need to grind down in
terms of Graphics consistency this stuff
Fair
is that a yes we'll do it okay because I
really really want to see that list
because we're going to want to do a
whole giant series of meetings try to
grind all this stuff down
okay
um
so I want to come back to the names here
okay we simply can't have
you know so highlight graph
is a take the graph and highlight it
yes
okay so that's a perfectly you know we
could have because there is an object
okay there is an object okay same thing
with mesh same thing with image
right
that's fine
Okay so
um
let's
okay
so what is wrong with having highlighted
be the rapper for static highlighting
I don't know that there's anything wrong
with that
okay
um
I mean that would be consistent with
those options have nothing to do with
many use cases
yeah I understand that but I mean we can
probably Define that separately
that's okay
I mean it's like saying Style
you know XXX comma red whoops
right that's works and so to me you know
what are you going to do to highlight
this well we've got a different form of
highlighting
you know here as in a plot
which I think is okay
I mean we might we might want this to
inform how you do default highlighting
in a plot but that's a different story
but I think that's what we should do for
the for the wrapper for the static
wrapper but also
you know what are the possible settings
they're going to be quite different in a
different uh I think I think this one
has to be pulled in with this one here
okay we're not going to have a different
name it's just too confusing for people
um
now
the next question is
I think that
the other one should be called Dynamic
highlighting Arrow true or false or
whatever it is or whatever the whatever
the option is the thing you're calling
Dynamic plot highlight I think should be
called Dynamic highlighting
okay
I'm kind of wondering
whether
Dynamic highlighting and highlighting
should be the same option and whether
there should be a way of indicating
because I think it's nice to be able to
say
I don't know maybe not what is
highlighting the non-dynamic version
what is that what are the settings for
that that's what you're pulling so you
typically often have to open that ref
page
one of the things you might want to do
is to point out what it is to be
highlighted
like what yeah actually yeah right
exactly and you you want to you want to
do what would otherwise be a screen
capture basically
right sort of but it's kind of a tough
tough thing to pull off to both do the
screen capture and hold your mouse at a
particular point I know I know I know
but I think this is a the wrong name for
okay so look one thing is
I think it's a good defensive naming to
call this one Dynamic highlighting and
then whatever it is now this thing here
is saying I want a frozen highlight of a
particular kind correct yes correct
why are you showing Dynamic highlight
when this examples aren't updated so
okay but but what should it be how do
you specify where you want the mouse to
be effectively
so so we have two forms one is a list
thing and one is
you know using placed
nobody will ever figure it out
I got a suggestion okay
a rule
well no what I'm thinking is this
okay
that what we're really doing is
decorating Dynamic highlighting so
Dynamic highlighting goes to automatic I
don't know what that is by default a
ball probably right but let's say it's a
a drop line
okay
but now you need to specify I actually
don't want the dynamic highlighting I
want
yeah what I want to do now I've got that
Dynamic highlighting specified but I
want to do
you know really what this is like it's a
freeze highlights freeze highlighting
or something
I guess it's got to be an option
it can't be a plot wrapper it's got to
be an option right
yes
but what it really is then is I mean it
could be a wrapper around the setting
yes it could be
that what it really wants to say is
where's the mouse
in user coordinates or in scaled
coordinates or whatever else that's
really what all it's saying is where's
the mouse
am I not correct
yes right now but soda for the future I
think that there are other things that
we would like to add a vocabulary for
like local data yeah okay
zeros that's nice yeah
but now what about multi
multi-highlights
we probably want that as well right
multi-static yes yeah multi-static
highlighting now
in this case here there's only one mouse
cursor
but so
I mean really what this is so you're
suggesting Maybe
um
you know something like
something like that
um
I think this is the one that should be I
mean it's a little weird to say Dynamic
highlighting
well okay so the other possibility would
be to call this option highlighting
or plot highlighting
men deserve secret mechanism work or is
it broken at the moment
uh wait
what secret are talking about uh the
default Mouse position
I
okay
I don't think that's working okay
if we called it plot highlighting
is that sensible or is that then
inconsistent with all the chart this
that and the other things
and we got plot range which which works
for everything right we have lots of
things that start with plot that work
everywhere
you know plot range plot range padding
you know
Etc
so plot highlighting is a possibility
so then highlighted
is the wrapper form and plot
highlighting
which where if you say Arrow drop line
would be a dynamic thing
is frozen highlighting better than
placed
don't be stupid no it's no good but but
the place isn't good either
and also
uh you know some things
you know like uh
well maybe you want the dynamic Max I
didn't figure that
but some things are not super Dynamic
they're sort of there you know
um
and and this introduces another symbol
anyway
well okay but look one thing you might
want is I might want Dynamic drop lines
but then I want my might want to static
something else yes so it's got clearly
got to be a list of plot highlighting
has got to be a list of things
potentially yes yes and then each one
you know what bothers me about placed
is that placed is really a thing that
says where to place the thing that's
inside the placed
well maybe that's what you're arguing
this is
it's a weird weird thing to say that
that freezes it
well maybe not
maybe you're right
so then this would look like
but then we should have only that form
we should not have some other form
okay place this x y
I mean I assume you're adding placed to
plot label right
mm-hmm
so because it's got to work for
everything you know it can't be the case
that you have to go ask you whether it
works
see what I'm saying
right
I think I like that actually I think
this is this is a workable thing so plot
highlighting Arrow drop line is the
dynamic version and then placed x y
means it's a drop line but it is in a
specific place
now I hope I see so we are on the same
page you you have two options
no one option what
I don't know dynamic highlighter just
plot highlighting okay
okay
after your place so do place to you know
whatever close comma all ball
yeah right so that's a fixed drop line
that x y and a dynamic ball
right so here's my concern are there any
forms of annotation that might
themselves need to be placed above below
whatever else
not sure I understand the question well
if there's a label do you want to say
where the label goes right and in the
dynamic case do you want to dynamically
label always above
if so you might want to use placed
around that drop line thing you get what
I'm saying
not using place to mean freeze it
right
but I think
and I I mean I don't know whether the
things that you can do with highlighting
you can also do with labeling
and I think there's you know some
overlap yeah but but it's got to be
perfectly consistent the way placed is
used has to be perfectly consistent yes
between the labeling and this case
all right let's very briefly look at
graphic design this is this is a good
start whether this thing is placed or
something different I'm not sure
okay
let's see the other you know possibility
that occurs to me is maybe kind of weird
is
you know we could use dynamic as a
wrapper
you gotta be freaking prison no
absolutely not absolutely totally not
okay it has a definite meaning and it's
not that
um okay
design Folk
see that
okay
it doesn't feel quite right maybe it
needs more space maybe it needs I don't
know what's wrong with it
something's not right
I also don't like the um the decimal
wiggling you see what I'm saying what do
we do about the decimal wiggling
Roger Brett you understand what I'm
saying
you mean so like you know in the second
place where you know it moves a little
or yeah no the fact that it has
different numbers of digits depending on
where I am
see what I'm saying
why is it 0.75 it should be 0.750 so it
doesn't Wiggle all over the place
see what I'm saying it shouldn't be
puffing in and out
as I move on the Curve am I making sense
I mean that should just say
0.001 or 0.002 or whatever it is it
shouldn't I don't think I think it
should be fixed precision
I'm making sense I mean I think I know
how to okay wait wait first of all we
have to decide what we want what's
what's happening right now is no good
right so if and if it is going to Puff a
fish okay whatever the I don't know what
a fish do this but then what said yes I
got the joke but keep on going right the
um
then then it should go out from the
middle so I I know how to do this when
when we have when we can look at
everything the thing here I don't think
we can look at everything beforehand not
realistically no no I I think all we
need to look at is the plot range I
think we can do reasonable heuristics
based on
you know the fact that X is going from 0
to 10 and Y is going from
minus one to one fine
by the way isn't the same issue I've
seen the same issue in in images I
believe
where
if I go here
and I go to
for example this
thing antiquated
yeah I mean that's not wiggling as badly
it is still wiggling
it really shouldn't wiggle you should
have the same heuristics here because
you know the pixel values right
so leave the space for that extra digit
am I making sense
and what's that look weird
I don't think so
like you know because the exercise
about this
whether it should wiggle or not I agree
that we should avoid wiggling as much as
possible yeah but the question is then
if we if we don't wiggle then we have a
space in this case for that 97 uh
there'd be a space before the 97.
I think that would look weird
in this case better than wiggling I
think in my opinion
well the other possibility to prevent
wiggling is to truncate the decimal
digits on the right so that you always
have a fixed number of digits
so if it's more you know on the left
it decreases the digits on the right
which might be okay too
I'm making sense so it's a number form
setting where it's a fixed number of
digits
I I think it is a better behavior for
dynamic but for static do you still want
the extra space
no
and that's okay because there is no
scenario in which you'll flip a ruling
so to speak between Dynamic and static
in other words it's a it's a programming
action to go between those two
right in the static case your puffer
fish has been taxidermied into yes and
it's fully whatever cooked yes
um
okay
what do you think about the look of that
actual tooltip and by the way whatever
that's doing this horrifying thing that
you know that very minimalist
tooltip has to be somehow consistent
with this
I think one thing with that is the the
background of that tooltip is the exact
same color as the line now I wonder if
it should be lighter
because it's you know a larger area yeah
yeah no I I kind of agree with you I
mean the same Hue but lighter is what
you're saying but then you you know is
the type going to be visible too
I mean I would make the project be black
right
because I don't think there's a
guarantee that the line is dark enough
that the type can be white anyway no
Jeremy your comments on this well I I
agree the colors shouldn't match it's
merging with the line in a weird way
it's also following the angle of the
line maybe unintentionally which bothers
me
where it's just kind of overlapping that
line as much as possible
I wish it was yeah like here if it was
flipped to the right maybe there's not
room
it'd be better
the Philippian is dominated so yeah
those are more readable right
the Philippian currency is only bounded
by the polar range it's trying to avoid
going outside okay
okay listen I think I should be going to
another meeting here could you guys
continue here and just talk about some
of the design stuff I think you need to
do an iteration of that
um I think you should also talk about
whether highlight with its ugly yellow
could be slightly modified highlighted
sorry it could be slightly modified to
be a bit more consistent between what
it's What's Happening Here well the
highlighted here which is this wherever
it was the um I don't even know where I
had it
I don't understand that
um
something went horribly wrong here I
mean that that that Dynamic highlight
that would be now highlighted of
wait a minute highlighted is intended to
be dynamically or statically highlighted
highlighted should be statically
highlighted if I explicitly have
highlighted
in my sequence of Curves I want it to be
statically highlighted yes right
yeah that's what you want anyway the
question so it's a highlighted wrapper
would be
static and dynamic following the option
yeah so one argument is going to be a
static thing
you know and then if you go to arguments
then
you know it becomes that's fine so the
default is a static thing
yep
that's fine
and then we use placed in what not in
the same way as in plot highlighting
or a two argument form if highlighted
oh I see if you have a ball highlighting
you can say that you place it in that
particular place
mm-hmm
and presumably placed allows you to have
multiple X Y pairs here or does it
you can
we can explicitly make sure that it does
well so that's multi-placing where you
have multiple things like this okay
anyway you guys need to work on and I
have no idea what this looks like for a
um I mean you haven't done geoplots or
anything like that here but I mean you
need to be thinking ahead to those yep
um also I have no idea what this does on
a logarithmic plot this is
okay but but it's got to go to exponents
and things and that's going to have a
lot of wiggling
like if it's I mean if I do
doesn't look like it oh 96 there
that's very wiggler for us
well I mean that's in my opinion too
many digits yes and
I want to see what happens when it goes
to scientific notation
uh see how do I get this to work well
I'll just do this
but I think it's current formatting it's
preventing it from going to scientific
notation at all it looks like
oh that's pretty curly that's right
what's that
it is trying to prevent go to uh
scientific yeah and by the way no
trailing decimal points please ever
see what I'm saying
well you got to figure out what to do
with Centric notation
and whether it's going to look
crazy
to up puff so to speak
it may not look as crazy as the
horizontal
anybody design folk have an opinion
about that
what do you mean by up
because it's going to have an exponent
right so it's got to be taller so I mean
I personally hate these axis ticks that
mix
exponential and non-exponential
and if you think about it sorry some do
some don't I know I know so but but if
you have it in there in the call out
that some are not exponential and some
are exponential
it will surely wiggle if you're always
it'll puff up it won't necessarily well
it might have to it might have to wiggle
look I think there's another solution
for wiggling okay
I think I think if you lock the right
things
for some absolutely bizarre reason I was
thinking about train tracks yesterday
and real and thermal expansion of train
tracks and they're a case where you know
there is severe wiggle right if you
compute you know it's like a I forget
what it was like a 50-foot if you had a
continuous piece of iron from Boston to
New York it changes in length by 50 feet
or something but that's you know in
practice you lock the end of each
section each you know whatever it is 70
foot section of track you lock the end
you know you lock the pieces down with
those you know and then it bows out
rather than we're going not that we have
that option here but I'm just saying I
think there might be something where for
example you maintain uh the braces in
the same place but you have different
different amounts of space in the middle
I don't know
you gotta try it
and I have to go to this other meeting
so I am going to
depart here
um okay and but we're gonna need to pick
this up one more time and after you've
got some more design stuff I don't know
whether you want to try and pick that up
at the beginning of the next design
review that's at 4pm Eastern or
um or you want to make that be that a
two hour block for calculus and algebra
yeah don't mix the two this that's going
to be a disaster I think okay fine all
right see you guys at top of the next
hour I'm going to depart here you can
keep uh chatting
um
so okay see you later
bye